au marché central il est interpellé par
des policiers qui le soupçonne d'une
tentative de vol sur une voiture parce
que je
l'homme est aussitôt menotté les
policiers poursuivent leur vérifications
ils ont demandé mon nom j'ai dit mon nom
ils ont dit le véhicule est à vous
monsieur je suis dépassé il s'agissait
en fait de son propre véhicule malgré
tout il demeurera menotté pendant
plusieurs minutes je dis mais pourquoi
je suis encore dans les menottes si
c'est ma voiture les policiers
souhaitent le libérer mais constate
qu'ils n'ont pas la clé de leur propre
menottes je me suis senti vraiment
humilié là ils ont fait appel
aux policiers à leurs collègues qui sont
venus après une quinzaine de minutes je
vous dirais que il y a certainement un
manquement Marcel Savard peine à
comprendre pourquoi les policiers
n'avaient pas deux clients leur
possession l'individu est menotté trop
longuement sans raison aucune diffusé
sur les médias sociaux la vidéo de
l'arrestation a déclenché une tempête de
réaction une situation comme celle vécue
par ce citoyen affecte le sentiment de
confiance entre la police et nos
communautés montréalaises estiment
responsable de la cyclourdie publique de
Montréal le ministre François Bonnardel
promet de faire les virifications qui
s'imposent auprès du SPVM c'est un
profilage racial qui a porté un
préjudice moral à ma personne à la
lumière de ces événements le député
solidaire andrésila demande à Québec de
ne pas porter un appel la récente
décision de la Cour supérieure sur les
interceptions sans motif si il a été et
intercepté en vertu de l'article 6-3-6
du Code de la sécurité routière il y a
motivé qu'il y avait la du profilage
racial Brice de ça confie qu'il peine à
fermer l'oeil depuis son arrestation
même ma famille a eu mal si le procédé
au dépôt d'une plainte en déontologie
policière il n'écarte pas de se tourner
vers les tribunaux
et puis elle dit en fin de journée la
Fraternité des policiers a réagi oui
parce que depuis jeudi depuis la
diffusion de cette vidéo il y a
plusieurs élus qui ont réagi par
l'entremise des médias sociaux notamment
plus récemment cet après-midi Denis
Langlade sur son compte Twitter et si ce
qui vaut à la Fraternité des policiers
de demander où aux élus de rester
prudent et voici ce qu'on dit dans une
société de droit les élus devraient
s'abstenir de partager leurs impressions
sur le caractère d'une opération
policière avant que tous les faits ne
leur soient connus ils éviteraient
notamment un alimenté le désengagement
policier alors qu'est-ce que c'est le
désengagement politique c'est lorsque
des policiers décident de ne plus
intervenir parce qu'il en craignent les
répercussions sur leur travail sur leur
vie personnelle je rappelle en terminant
que le Service de police de Montréal
mais naturellement une enquête sur cette
affaire